hey this is pressure Walker I want to
thank George who sent me this problem
the problem was given to George by his
seventh grade math teacher ms v consider
the following table all numbers in the
first column have been increased by the
same percentage P to give the results in
the second column the resulting numbers
are coded each digit is replaced by a
letter a given letter stands for the
same digit every time it appears in that
column what is the value of P the
percentage increase now I have received
an email from a blind person who
requested that when possible I read out
the numbers that are on the screen so
let me read out this table it consists
of eight rows with two columns the first
column consists of a two-digit number
and the second column consists of two
letters so let me read it out row by row
20 G C 15 I J 45 AC 35 cg7 TJC ad HF 25e
B and 60 D G so can you figure out this
seemingly impossible seventh-grade math
problem give it a try and when you're
ready keep watching the video for a
solution
so there may be many ways to solve this
problem here's how I figured it out and
you can share your method in the
comments since the second column has
distinct whole numbers we can limit the
search to positive fractional increases
so let's search for a common factor of
the numbers in the first column I
consider the numbers thirty five and
twenty thirty five is equal to five
times seven and twenty is equal to five
times four so we can consider the common
factor of five
this gives the possibilities of
fractional increases of 1/5 2/5 3/5 4/5
and fighttips these correspond to
percentage increases of 20% 40% 60% 80%
and a hundred percent which one is it
notice that 80 increased by 25% is equal
to 100 which is a three-digit number but
the resulting number for 80 has only two
digits
therefore the percentage increase has to
be less than 25%
this means the percentage increase is
equal to 20% and you can check that that
works for example 20 increase by 20%
is equal to 24 and 35 increase by 20% is
equal to 42 and these are the same
digits in the answer just reversed
24:42 and G C and C G and you could
check it works there are no other
contradictions in the table so the
correct answer is 20% did you figure it
out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math you can catch me on my
blog mind your decisions if you like
this video you can check out my books
which are listed in the video
description and you can support me on
patreon if you have a math topic you can
email me presh at mind your decisions
calm and you can catch me on social
media either at mind your decisions or a
pressure tell Walker